de
[Musique]
Noël
madame monsieur bonsoir voici les titres
de l'actualité de ce lundi 24 décembre
en Mauritanie une famille française a
été attaquée par des voleurs il y a
quatre morts dont deux enfants le Père
grièvement blessé est hospitalisé sur
place mouvement de grève des urgentistes
hospitaliers qui demandent le paiement
de leurs heures supplémentaires alors
que les médecins généralistes qui
effectuent des gardes auront une prime
de 150 €. à mégac près de Bordeaux deux
petites filles de 6 et 12 ans sont
mortes vraisemblablement intoxiquées au
monoxyde de carbone par le chauffaau de
la salle de bain la célébration de Noël
au Vatican bien sûr par le pape Benoît X
qui a dévoilé la crèche mais aussi à
Bethléem où la cérémonie devrait avoir
cette année un faste
particulier et puis vous verrez dans ce
journal une démonstration scientifique
de l'intelligence animale parfois
supérieure à celle de l'homme du
chimpanzé mathématicien au corbeau
bricoleur certaines espèces sont loin
d'être bêtes en Mauritanie une famille
française a été attaquée sur une route à
250 km à l'est de noakchot il y a quatre
morts dont deux enfants la 5è personne
le père de famille a été grièvement
blessé par bal le président français
Nicolas Sarkozi a affirmé que tout
serait fait pour rapatrier les blessés
et le mort dans les meilleurs
délis ils avaient choisi la plénitude du
désert mauritanien pour passer les fêtes
de fin d'année en famille c'est ici sur
la route qui relie noakchot la capitale
à la petite ville touristique d'alg
qu'une famille française est tombée dans
une embuscade pendant son pique-nique
trois hommes armés de fusil d'assaut ont
tué quatre personnes et gravement blessé
le père de famille alors selon les
autorités c'est la piste du crime
crapuleux qui est privilégié même si en
raison des kalashnikov on peut supposer
qu'il s'agit d'un groupe un peu
structuré en tout cas qu'il y a des
moyens des moyens d'attaquer ALG n'est
pas du tout une ville cible pour pour
des djihadistes d'alqaïda ce n'est pas
une région spécifiquement touristique ce
n'est pas une région spécifiquement
dangereuse c'est en visite à l'hôpital
Necker que Nicolas Sarkozi a appris la
nouvelle et confirmé la mort des
Français tous les moyens sont mobilisés
pour rapatrier ses familles uncor et
puis des blessés une enquête est lancée
pour savoir exactement ce qui s'est
passé et à la minutesù je vous parle il
est trop tôt pour dire
exactement les raisons de cette
agression ce soir le mobile politique
semble écarté les forces de sécurité
mauritaniennes peent à contrôler cette
zone parcouru par des trafiquants
d'armes et de drogue cette attaque a
déstabilisé les tours
opérateurs on a été très étonné parce
que la destination mauritanienne est
réputée justement pour sa son côté
paisible et et tranquille le père
grièvement blessé à la jambe a rejoint
l'hôpital de noakchot il devrait être
prochainement rapatrié en France seul
voilà c'est une enquête signée Karine
Comadi Bruno Vigier et Marie Cazo au
Chad poursuit du procès des 10 accusés
dans l'affaire de l'Arche de Zoé les
familles demandent 1 million d'euros
pour chacun des 103 enfants enlevés les
bénévoles français aujourd'hui
paraissait plus tendu une des
infirmières Nalia mermi a eu un malaise
ce matin en cours de l'audience
reportage sur place à ma Guibert et
Frédéric
rank ce fut une journée éprouvante pour
les si membres de l'Arche de Zoé à la
sortie de l'AUD
etie Lelouche ont le visage figé les
accusés ont à peine dit un mot de la
journé et c'est à 5 qu'ils sont repartis
vers la prison
dejamena en fin de matinée Nadia mer
l'infirmière a fait appel à un médecin
un malaise qui nécessitera finalement
son évacuation vers la base militaire
française un incident dans une journée
consacré au parti civil d'abord avec le
témoignage de ces hommes si pèes
représentant les familles qui ont confié
les enfants à l'Arche de Zoé puis avec
les ploiries de leurs avocats qui ont
des mots très durs pour é bretau menteur
manipulateur qui sont ven spontanément
j'ai pas pris tout le temps de
préparerir mais je sais que c'est des
mots qui vienent tout droit du cœur
parce que justement prant ce dossier je
saais que c'était pour une noble
causefend les
enants interp par un autre avocat des
par civil vous n'étiez pas autorisé lu à
sortir 103 enfants du pays sans avertir
l'État chadien est-ce qu'il a été de
mauvaise fois ou non on a démontré qu'il
était de mauvaise fois dès le départ il
a berné tout le monde il a berné les
autorités de son pays il a berné les
autorités tchadiennes il a berné les
employés et il a berné même ses propres
amis l'audience reprendra aprèsdemain
avec le réquisitoire de l'avocat général
puis les pldoiries de la défense la
défense qui devrait demander
l'acquitement pour les six Français de
l'Arche de Zoé en mettant en avant un
argument principal la bonne foi en
France les urgentistes sont en grève à
partir d'aujourd'ui aujourd'hui en dépit
des offres faites par le ministre de la
Santé Roseline Bachelot il demande que
leurs heures supplémentaires impayées
depuis des années leur Soi rémunérées ce
qui représente 8 à 900 millions d'euros
pour l'heure la ministre ne dispose que
de 570 millions en tout état de cause
ces grèves n'empêcheront pas les
urgences d'accueillir les malades qui se
présentent et les négociations vont
démarrer le 7 janvier de leur côté les
médecins généralistes libéraux vont
recevoir une prime de 150 € pour
effectuer des gardes ce qui devrait
avoir pour effet de désengorger les
urgences et surtout de répondre à la
demande dans les zones éloignées des
hôpitaux trop souvent en effet le 15 est
débordé pendant les périodes de fête
reportage près de Toulouse Laurence
bvillard et David Bress un cabinet
médical ouvert la veille de Noël pas
toujours facile à trouver c'est pour
inciter les médecins à assurer leur
consultation les veilles de jour fériers
que le ministère de la Santé vient de
débloquer 750000 € il ont touché une
astreinte c'est-à-dire la veille des
jours fériers et le samedi après-midi il
vient d'être négocié un accord avec la
caseassurance maladie qui prévoit le
financement de cette astreinte chaque
médecin touchera 150 € par jour de garde
le but désengorger les services des
urgence ici par exemple à Toulouse nous
sommes au 15 pour cette veille de fête
le centre de régulation a doublé ses
effectifs mais malgré cela c'est le rush
il y a deux fois plus d'appels qu'un
lundi normal je pense que c'est la
conjection de deux facteurs premièrement
il y a une augmentation trèsnette des
pathologies vernales et de l'autre côté
il y a une réduction des moyens pour
traiter ces patients que ce soit
hospitalier que ce soit une réduction
des moyens de la médecine libérale qui
en cette période comme tout le monde
veut prendre ses congés le problème se
pose de manière encore plus criante en
dehors des agglomérations
d'cord ce qui nous pose un problème ce
sont des gens qui appellent pour avoir
des médecins de garde alors
qu'aujourd'hui ce n'est pas un jour
Ferrier et que nous n'avons pas de
système de garde en tout cas pour les
secteurs éloignés de Toulouse les jours
de fête il y a toujours des médecins g
pour leséveill il faut espérer que les
primes proposées encourageront les
médecins à répondre présent en Corse la
gendarmerie de cargz a été mitraillé la
nuit dernière il n'y a pas de blessé les
enquêteurs s'interrogent sur les liens
éventuels entre cet attentat et ceux des
jours précédent avec la condamnation à
perpétuité d'an Colona car à chaque fois
ce sont les services de l'État qui sont
visés et Michel aliomaré le ministre de
l'Intérieur a réuni les services de
police et de gendarmerie aujourd'hui
pour renforcer leur corps ordination
l'ancien gendarme de la cellule
antiterroriste de l'Élysée Paul baril a
été écroué cet après-midi misise en
examin dans le cadre d'une affaire liée
à l'exploitation d'une salle de jeux
parisienne il est soupçonné
d'association de malfaiteurs dans ce
dossier qui concerne aussi bien les
milieux marseillais Corse que
Parisiens dans le Nord près de
Valencienne c'est une vieille dame de 86
ans vivant seul qui a été retrouvé en
hypothermie dans sa maison allongée sur
le sol son poê à charbon ne fonctionnait
plus ce drame est en lumière la
difficulté des personnes âgées vivant
seules puisque cette dame bénéficiait
d'une aide ménagère et de repas servi à
domicile l'alerte a pu tout de même être
donnée mais en 24 heures la vieille dame
était déjà au bord du coma Fanny stamler
et
maréc la vieille dame a été retrouvée
inerte sur le sol de la cuisine en état
d'hypothermie la température du corps
descendu à 26°gr cette femme de 86 ans a
pourtant reçu la veille la visite d'une
aide à domicile et d'un porteur de
plateau repas de la
mairie sur sur une journée et dem
mi-temps il arrivé ça c'est surprenant
quoi parce que si vous dit c'est pas
quelqu'un qu'on laissé abandonner loin
de là c'est pas notre travail nous c'est
justement de s'occuper d'eux et c'est ce
qu'on s force de faire alors là c'est n
rien à comprendre la situation a basculé
en quelques heures le jour de son
malaise la vieille dame ne répond pas au
coup de sonnette de l'homme qui lui
apporte son plateau repas il repartira
sans donner l'alerte auprès des secours
ou de la mairie
on doit s'interroger quand les gens ne
répondent pas on doit pas
simplement se contenter de faire une
prestation le SAMU préfère tirer des
leçons plus générales de l'affaire pour
les grands froids comme pour la canicule
c'est la solidarité qui sauve les vies
servic sociau qui font un travail bien
entendu exceptionnel ne peuvent pas tout
ils ne peuvent absolument pas tout et
peut-être que lorsque le climat est rude
lorsque l'isolement est là il nous faut
tous être un pe peu plus attentif au
anciens soir la vieille dame est
toujours hospitalisée à Valencienne son
état est stable mais les médecins
refusent encore de se prononcer sur son
pronostic vital et puis c'est un autre
danger de l'hiver qui a coûté la vie à
deux jeunes adultes de 18 et 20 ans ils
sont tombés dans un lac gelé à
passicodon dans l'Aube près de TR la
glace a semble-t-il cédé sous leur poids
à mérigac dans une maison de la band
bordelaise deux petites filles sont
mortes vraisemblablement intoxiqué au
monoxyde de carbone bonne par le
chauffeau de la salle de bain les
petites filles de cousine n'ont pas pu
être réanimé trois autres personnes de
la maison ont été légèrement incommodé
Francis Mazoyer et Philippe dumil le
drame s'est produit dans cette maison de
mrigac une famille s était donné
rendez-vous pour partir réveillonné dans
le Lot vers midi le père a découvert sa
fille de 6 ans avec une cousine de 12
ans inanimée dans la salle de bain la
salle de bain était équipée d'un d'un
chauffe haut et les décès seraient
d'origine accidentale seraiit d à une
intoxication au au monoxyde de carbone
Pompi et SAMU ont tenté de réanimer les
fillettes pendant une heure sans
résultat l'enquête devra déterminer si
le chauffau était déectueux la salle de
bain était correctement ventilée mais le
froid et le brouillard ont peut-être
empêché l'évacuation du gaz on a des
phénomènes d'inversion et si la
combustion ne se fait pas bien les gaz
ne s'évacuent pas normalement à
l'extérieur et vous pouvez avoir une
concentration à l'intérieur des
habitations c'est pour ça qu'il est
essentiel de faire vérifier ces
installations de chauffage surtout en
cette période hivernale les pompiers
préconisent aussi installation de
détecteur car le monoxyde de carbone est
un gaz invisible et inodor qui peut
entraîner la mort en quelques minutes
lorsqu'on a des maots de tête déjà on a
une intoxication qui est avancée et
souvent les les les ces maots de tête
sont
précédés de de paralysie musculaire qui
font que les gens ne peuvent pas aller
ne peuvent pas aller ouvrir une fenêtre
ou une porte pour ventiler le local le
père de famille de 49 ans et deux
adolescents de 17 ans ont été légèrement
incommodés les autopsies des victimes
auront lieu dem absolument chaque année
en France on compte environ 6000
intoxications au monoxyde de carbone
dans 300 mortels autre conséquence de
cette météo hivernale la pollution est
maximum à Paris des microopoussières en
suspension dans l'air conséquence du
chauffage urbains des moteurs de voiture
et de la combustion industrielle stagne
sur la ville elle provoque gênes
respiratoires et allergie elles sont
donc liées au climat froid et au
brouillard la région ronalpe vit aussi
au rythme des P de pollution depuis une
semaine à Lyon l'émission de particules
est quatre fois supérieure à la moyenne
explication et surtout conseil avec
Benoît gadr et Olivier Jacquelin George
Chev est asthmatique depuis son plus
jeune âge ce septuagénre redoute la
pollution de l'air en ce moment il sort
le moins possible
oui a une grande gêne il a une grande
gêne je mets une demi-journé pour
récupérer quand je sors comme ça qu'il
fait froid et qu'il y a de la
brume
ouais cela fait bientôt une semaine que
l'air est pollué à Lyon l'explication on
la trouve en prenant de la hauteur voici
la nappe de brouillard qui recouvre la
ville au-dessus l'air est réchauffé par
les rayons du soleil en dessous il est
beaucoup plus froid les polluants sont
donc plaqués au sol il ne se dispersent
pas ces polluants ce sont des particules
émises par le chauffage et les voitures
leur volume est qu fois supérieur à la
moyenne habituelle on les observci en
rouge sur ce plan de
lion ce type d'épisode on l'avait pas
vécu depuis plusieurs années parce qu'on
n pas eu sur des conditions hivernales
en fait des anticyclones aussi longs sa
VZ que les hivers ces dernières années
ont été plutôt doux ces particules fines
indisposent les sujet fragil les jeunes
enfants les personnes souffrant
d'insuffisance respiratoire ou de
maladies cardiovasculairire pour des
gens qui sont déjà gênés une aggravation
de de leur gêne la sensation de
d'étouffer et puis pour des gens qui
sont cardiaques
éventuellement d'avoir un accident
coronarien aigu l'épisode de pollution
pourrait durer encore quelques jours
c'est la raison pour laquelle la
réduction de 20 kmh des vitesses
autorisées est maintenue dans le
département du rô et justement en
charante une imprimerie qui fabrique des
étiquettes est parvenu à réduire ses
émissions de carbone principal
responsable de la pollution avec une
recette toute simple ils utilisent moins
de matière plastique mode d'emploi avec
Gill Marinet et Valérie Luca
100 million c'est le nombre d'étiquettes
imprimé en 2007 sur les machines de
cette entreprise charantaise alors
comment réduire la production de carbone
d'abord en diminuant la matière première
nécessaire de 50 microns d'épaisseur
l'étiquette est passer à 38 MICR soit
20% de plastique en moins pour cela il a
fallu plusieurs mois d'études d'cès et
surtout au départ de la volonté je pense
que le problème de l'environnement il
est là qu portable on fait pas d'effort
et quand on sait que le pétrole augmente
effectivement les matières premières
vont augmenter elles augmentent aussi
bien il faut réduire le poids matière
dans notre travail c'est tout 120 tonnes
de rouleau plastiques économisés leur
fabrication leur transport aurit générer
autant de CO2 que par exemple 300
voitures effectuant 20000 km chacune
autre technique les peintures r solvant
rejetés par les machines sont brûlés
dans cet incinérateur tout récent ce qui
produit ass d'énergie pour diviser par
de la consommation de gaz destinée au
séchoir d'étiquette ça nous permet avec
la croissance nécessaire obligatoire de
l'entreprise sur le plan économique et
bien de au moins maintenir et idéalement
diminuer notre activité en en équivalent
carbone cette stratégie verte est née en
2004 lorsque l'usine s'est prêtée à l'un
des premiers bilans carbone proposé par
l'agence pour les économies d'énergie à
ce jour en France 600 entreprises ont
passé cet examen qui calcule précisément
leur production de gaz à effet de
serre comment réformer la profession de
taxi sans se mettre à dos toute la
corporation c'est le difficile Paris
dans lequel se lance le gouvernement les
taxis qui achètent leur licence jusqu'à
200000 € redoutent de perdre le bénéfice
de cet investissement si on supprime le
numérus closusus pour contourner la
difficulté le gouvernement envisage
d'accorder des licences d'un nouveau
type avec en prime une somme forfaitaire
de 50 € pour desservir les aéroports
parisiens
explication Valérie l rouge et Dominique
Bonet facile d'attraper un taxi à midi
un 24 décembre impossible en revanche de
connaître à l'avance le montant pour
rejoindre l'aéroport le plus proche
bonjour test grandeur nature or s'il
vous plaît ou avec le tarif unique
envisagé par le gouvernement notre
course coûterait 50 € aujourd'hui le
trafic est fluide arrivé à Orli le
compteur affiche nettement moins combien
ça fait 20,40 € avec la réforme elle
toucherait donc 30 € de plus pas
suffisant apparemment pour séduire ces
chauffeurs qui attendent parfois 2 heur
avant de prendre un passager oui non ça
dépend la circulation monsieur on met
souvent moins de 50 € d'accord mais il y
a des fois si on tombe dans les bouchons
quand il y a les grèves Ouaiss ça peut
monter vachement plus cher il faut
laisser le compteur comme ça c'est tout
pas faut pas changer les choses ça sert
à rien les clients eux sont plus
partagés avec une tarif unique c'est
plus facile pour tous les gens s'il est
le double du tarif normal non j'en vois
pas l'intérêt la capitale compte
aujourd'hui 16000 taxis c'est trop peu
le weekend et aux heures de pointe pour
Pier cette pénurie le gouvernement
souhaite créer un nouveau type de
licence des voitures uniquement sur
réservation avec tarif forfaitaire
inconcevable pour les taxis
traditionnels nous sommes totalement
opposés à cette proposition qui est de
créer des taxis parallèles ça serait de
nouveau une concurrence supplémentaire
il y a les navettes il y a les motos
transport de personne les artisans taxi
en sauront davantage sur les projets
gouvernementaux d'ici un mois rapport
doit être remis avant la fin
janvier cet après-midi à la tombée de la
nuit la crèche de Noël installée sur la
place Saint-Pierre a été dévoilé pois 16
est apparu à la fenêtre pour la bénir la
foule massée autour d'un immense sapin a
pu découvrir cette crèche géante où la
Nativité a été située dans une maison et
non pas dans une grotte l'âne et le bœuf
sont donc absents de la crèche cette
année et en direct de Bethléem sur la
place de la mangeoire devant la
basilique de la Nativité nous retrouvons
Charles en Derlin bonsoir Charles alors
est-ce qu'on peut dire que cette année à
Bethléem ces fêtes de la Nativité auront
un faste particulier
oui bien tout à fait je crois que c'est
la première fois depuis des années que
Bethléem connaît une véritable fête
comme vous pouvez l'entendre il y a
beaucoup de monde et beaucoup
d'ambiances sur la place où orchestre
Coral se succède sur l'estrade
l'atmosphère est à l'optimisme il y a un
mieux-être économ
les salaires ont été payés et il n'y a
plus cette grande pauvreté que nous
avons connu l'année dernière et puis
aussi les Palestiniens veulent croire en
cette reprise d'un processus de paix aux
promesses de la communauté
internationale lors de la dernière
conférence de Paris des milliards de
dollars qui doivent pleuvoir sur les
Palestiniens donc ce soir depuis très
longtemps Bethléem est en faitte merci
merci Charles pour ces explications nous
restons en Israël pour nous rendre à tel
avis qui est devenue au fil des années
la première place au monde pour le
commerce des diamants qui comme chacun
le sait messieurs sont les meilleurs
amis des femmes 50 % des diamants de la
planète passent par là et ces marchands
venus parfois d'enverse vendent y
compris dans les pays du Golf une façon
de réconcilier tout le monde autour de
ses cailloux hors de prix reportage
Philippe Rochot et Mossi
Armon n'entre pas qui veux dans la
forteresse du diamant à té Aviv la Bour
c'est sans doute l'endroit le mieux
protégé d'Israël 15000 personnes
échangent ici plusieurs milliers de
diamants venus d'Afrique de Russie ou du
Canada 15 milliards d'euros par an et
viive est devenue la première place du
diamant au monde et le diamant reste une
valeur sûre le diamant reste aura
toujours sa valeur même si vous acheter
un diamant aujourd'hui vous le revendez
dans 50 ans il ne pourra pas vraiment
perdre Bruno Troger diaman expériment
ici un nouvel appareil qui va déterminer
sous quel angle on pourra tailler le
diamant qu' rapporte d'Afrique du Sud
afin d'en tirer le meilleur parti
l'ordinateur va même déterminer comment
la coupe va mettre en valeur la lumière
que reflète le
diamant ensuite la pierre est acheminée
dans un centre de polissage comme
celui-ci dalaloui avec 800 ouvriers où
seul un diamant peut polir et tailler un
autre
diamant autrefois cette industrie
employait 50000 ouvriers en Israël ils
ne sont plus que 3000 avec la
concurrence de l'Asie ils craignent pour
le emplo le SMIC ici c'est 800 dollars
800ll 900 dollar à peu près alors
ENAR l'absence d'impôt sur le commerce
du diamant fait aussi le succès de la
pierre précieuse sur le marché de téaviv
et les étrangers viennent ici en ombre
comme Sandy qui choisit la B de son
mariage Mo j'habite
angleterreamstrmement plus cher en
Angleterre évidemment qu'ici donc c'est
beaucoup plus
avantageux les diamantaires israéliens
produisent aussi ces pièces dans les
pays émergents afin de contrer une forte
concurrence le plus étonnant est de voir
que les Israéliens parviennent à vendre
les diamants directement dans les pays
arabes comme si l'intérêt pour ces
pierres faisait oublier le conflit et le
boycotte des produits
israéliens en Colombie le mari d'Ingrid
betancour a lancé sur la jungle 22000
photos des enfants de l'otage Mélanie et
Lorenzo une opération financée grâce au
don du chanteur français Renault et qui
a été effectué en quatre vols au cours
du weekend dernier et puis dans le même
temps on apprend que les trois otages
dont la Guera marxiste a annoncé la
libération le 18 décembre ne seront pas
relâché avant Noël car la RAS
collaboratrice d'ingr béancour et son
fils de 3 ans Emmanuel né en captivité
ainsi qu'une parlementaire colombienne
Consuelo gonzalz devrait être libérée au
Venezuela reportage à Caracas Renault
Bernard et Frédéric
Brisset les otages sont attendus ici
aéroport militaire de la Carlota à
Caracas sorti des hangars plusieurs
hélicoptères de l'armée sont prêts à les
évacuer avec leur escorte quand ils
auront atterri signe encourageant la
sénatrice colombienne Cordoba qui
discute au côté d'Ugo Chavez avec les
FARC est toujours au
Venezuela vous avez de l'espoir pour ces
prochain jours oui oui oui
totalement en réalité la libération des
otages pour Noël semble compromise la
presse vénézuélienne affirme que le
Brésilien Loula qui veut lui aussi jouer
les médiateurs perturbe le
processus il y aurait surtout les
opérations de l'armée colombienne qui
empêcheraient la Guera de déplacer les
otages facilement dans l'année 2002 ils
étaient autour de 17000 combattants
aujourd'hui ils sont moins de 9000 Clara
rorace l'amie d'Ingrid béancour ici à
gauche de l'écran son fils de 3 ans
n'est en captivité et la parlementaire
Consolo gonzalz serait toujours au cœur
de la jungle l'enfer vert Carlos norgard
l'a connu c'était à Nol 8
le pilote civil était prisonnier des FAR
la guerri exig une rançon pour le
libérer j'ai eu de la chance pour Noël
ils m'ont autorisé à envoyer un message
radio à ma famille je crois que pour ces
otages la situation est pire
ma dans le communiqu les ont promis de
remettre les TR otages au Venezuela pour
Noël ce soirac réveill sans
en espérant que leses soi libérés avant
une nouvelle échéance des rois magages
le 6 janvier et puis au Niger les deux
journalistes Thomas Dandois et Pierre
crisson arrêté alors qu'il tournait un
magasine pour haré sont inculpés
d'atteinte à la sûreté de l'État et
passible de la peine de mort ils se sont
rendus dans le nord du Niger interdit à
la presse région où les touareges sont
entrés en rébellion reporteur sans
frontière cet après-midi appelle le
président du Niger à la clémence et juge
leur inculpation disproportionné et puis
on vient d'apprendre en revanche la
libération du français Gwen lugui
retenu en otage DEP depuis le 16
décembre dans le nord-est de la Somalie
il est donc aujourd'hui libéré en
Grande-Bretagne sanction extrêmement
sévère pour les automobilistes qui
utilisent leur téléphone portable mais
aussi leur lecteur MP3 ou même leur
système GPS en conduisant ils enc
désormais une peine allant jusqu'à 2 ans
de prison Arne bouté et Dominique
Marotel il y a des réflexes encore durs
à prendre pour les chauffeurs de taxi
chéri je vais devoir accrocher
là même avec son oreillette celui-ci
risque jusqu'à 2 ans de prison en cas de
conduite dangereuse
ou depuis 4 ans les amendes ne suffisent
pas impossible de faire taire les
bavards la solution prison satisfait
d'abord les plus
vulnérables c'est très très bien je suis
plus en sécurité comme
cela c'est sans doute une bonne chose
car cela peut causer des accidents
graves portable volant causé la mor
d'une quinzaine de personnes et fait ici
blessés des pees plus lourd en cas de
conduite dangereuse c'est une bonne
chose les gens vont enfin comprendre que
les accidents sont
graves de son petit pavillon BR
représente l'une des principales
association d'automobilistes il prône le
strict respect du code de la route mais
ne supporte pas cette menace que brandit
le
gouvernement si vous considérez les
conducteurs comme des adultes ils
respecteront la loi et
sinon alors ils deviendront mécontents
et le Premier ministre Gordon Brown
devra se trouver un nouveau travail la
lecture d'un Journal ou d'une carte au
volant devient également passible de
prison 500000 anglais ne respecteraient
pas la loi qui déjà interdit
l'utilisation du portable en conduisant
le gouvernement tente de faire
peur en rappelant qu'au volant c'est la
messagerie qui
répond si votre gros chien pomme
reconnaît votre voix si votre caniche de
d' lis et se tenir à table c'est
peut-être parce qu'ils ont appris tout
seul avec leurs petites cellules grises
de nombreux scientifiques preuv à
l'appui nous montrent que les animaux
sont capables de réfléchir de fabriquer
des outils et parfois de calculer plus
vite qu'un humain Nicolas chatau et
Philippe
jacelin à première vue les chimpanzés de
l'Université de Kyoto sont des singes
comme les autres et pourtant depuis
quelques mois certains d'entre eux
suivent un entraînement particulier les
scientifiques ont appris à trois
chimpanzé de à compter jusqu'à 9 et à
classer les chiffres du plus petit au
plus
grand les chercheurs ont augmenté la
difficulté en masquant les chiffres
après un lapse de temps de plus en plus
court et là stupeur les jeunes
chimpanzés sont capables de reconstituer
la suite de chiffres à une vitesse
incroyable la plupart du temps sans se
tromper et pu le jeu est rapide plus
l'écart avec les étudiants humains se
creuse conclusion la mémoire visuelle
immédiate des jeunes P surpasse la
nôtre les gens pensent souvent que les
humains sont les êtres vivants les plus
intelligents sur terre mais je pense que
ces recherche montrre que c'est
totalement
faux autre exemple dans la nature cette
espèce de corbeau est connu pour
fabriquer des tiges à partir de branches
des tiges très utiles pour manger ou
creuser mais à Oxford on a trouvé une
surdouée Bettis et son nom se retrouvent
face à un panier de grain posé au fond
d'un tube à sa disposition une tige
droite sans grand intérêt mais là encore
les chercheurs ne croient pas leurs yeux
lorsque Betti se met à caler la tige
sous un morceau d'adhésif à la tordre
pour la courber fabriquer un crochet et
faire remonter le panier l'oiseau vient
de façonner un outil parfaitement
adapté finalement les animaux nous sont
très proches ils sont capables de
mémoriser ils sont sont capables de
solidarité ils sont capables d'affection
ils sont capables de mentir il y a une
chose qui nous distingue très
certainement c'est la perception de
l'animal à imaginer le futur les humains
ne sont pas au bout de leur surprise
récemment ces éléphants du zoau New York
ont vu arriver un grand miroir dans leur
enclos premier réflexe chercher derrière
renifler puis se regarder dedans pour
savoir si APIs l'éléphante la plus
curieuse avait conscience d'elle-même
les chercheurs ont dessiné une croix sur
son front royable arrive APPI se touche
le front avec la trompe elle se voit
dans le miroir longtemps l'homme a pensé
que ses facultés était réservé à
lui-même et au primates les plus évolués
mais peu à peu il découvre que de
nombreuses formes d'intelligence
existent ailleurs dans le règne animal
de quoi faire vaciller la tour d'ivoire
d'Homo
sapiens et en ces période de Noël de
plus en plus de Français retrouvent le
chemin de l'église à Sartrouville la
nouvelle église jean23 qui vient d'être
sacré a fait le plein ce soir pour la
messe de 18h30 la toute première des
trois messes de Noël sur place le
reportage de Frédéric montaille avec
Damien Louvet la nouvelle église jean-23
est à l'image de
Sartrouville moderne
rectangulaire ici pas de vitre pas de
cloche les traditionnelles peintures ont
été remplacées par un ordinateur et un
écran
géantumto 18h3 fait sal
comble environ 500
[Applaudissements]
fidèles chaque année il y a de plus en
plus d'enfants au catéchisme il y a de
plus en plus de jeunes à l'omoneries des
collèges et des lycées
et C cet accroissement de la communauté
chrétienne a été à l'origine en la
construction de cette nouvelle église et
parmi les nouveaux
chrétiens
au centre leur animatrice pastorale
félicité boom depuis 4 mois les deux
frères se préparent à être
baptisés rencontr le Christ en fait par
que
jement en
fait j'ai deréti pour mvrir le
cur les TR jeunes ass à la messe ce soir
ils mettront leur foi chrétienne en
pratique en servant un repas au plus
démunis de Sartrouville
la nuit de la Nativité c'est aussi la
tradition du repas de famille avec en
dessert l'incontournable bûche de Noël
une tradition à l'origine païenne qui
correspond au solstice d'hiver
l'objectif était de faire brûler le plus
lentement possible une très grosse bûche
pour protéger la maison et assurer
richesse et abondance aujourd'hui faute
de cheminée la bûche se retrouve dans
l'assiette avec des versions très
modernes et parfois très luxueuses
Florence bouquilla et Lionel
Langlade délicatement déposer chaque
pétale de rose sur le biscuit macaron
pour réaliser cette bûche nommée ISP 30
personnes ont ré toute la nuit normal ce
soir la collection hiver vit son apogé
et voici l'étrange bûche du futur
baptisé désir design par son créateur
jean-pavin une feuille argenté en robe
la coque tout chocolat qui protège la
mousse saveur fève de cacao toréfié
marié à un improbable coulis poivron et
piment moi j'ai imaginé ouvrir une boîte
casser le couvercle et ensite on a la
cuillère la mouche chocolat à
l'intérieur du du tube donc c'est un peu
ça l'esprit chaque année ce grand chef
pâtissier ose mais sa buche la plus
vendue est aussi la plus classique
simple biscuit macaron ganaché de
chocolat noir à mer de 29 à 49 € autre
grand pierre Hermet l'inspiration lui
vient toujours au printemps voici le
croquis de sa bûche à la truffe noire du
périgor biscuit moux aux amandes
torréfié et crème de mascarpone à la
truffe
noire
en fait on a le croquant de l'amande
l'onctuosité du biscuit et le délicat
parfum de la truffe qui petit à petit se
révèle jusqu'à devenir prépondérant dans
dans la dégustation donc c'est c'est
c'est c'est un CR d'eau de truf on va
dire un dessert rare et cher bien sûr
245 € 150 exemplaires seulement vendu
avec une truffe noire de 15 g et ça
râppe et puis la vue de froid actuel
fait le bonheur de ceux qui veulent
aller skier en moyenne montagne la neige
est déjà au rendez-vous r lesv la
station de La Bresse à havert reportage
Christine Bos et Jean-Pierre
pasteur cette année pour les fêtes de
Noël la famille la fond a choisi de se
retrouver dans un chalet d'vuges quatre
générations réunies autour de la gueule
89 ans cohabit pendant une semaine on
sait pas comment ça va terminer mais
pour
l'instant pour l'instant ça a bien
commencé alors on espère que tout va
bien se passer heureusement à La Bresse
il y a plein de choses à faire de
laaluge pour Maële des raquettes pour
Mireille et sa sœur et du ski pour les
garçons car non seulement il fait grand
beauau depuis 10 jours mais la neige est
au rendez-vous c'est une session
familiale où les PES sont pas trop
difficiles en plus dans un domaine qui
est bien couvert par les canons à neige
donc ce qui permet de de seier un peu un
peu tout le temps et et en effet c'est
bon pour tous les
niveaux situé à 1200 d'altitude La
Bresse a souffert l'année dernière du
manque d'enneigement la plus grande
station desvoges a même dû fermer en
janvier pendant 15 jours alors avec 70
cm de neige au sommet des pistes la
saison s'annonce
prometteuse toutes les pistes sont
ouverte il y a à peu près 50 à 60 cm de
neige partout ce qui est ce qui est
vraiment l'idéal et là comment ça
s'annonce pour les jours à venir et bien
écoutez tous les hôtels sont complets à
mon avis les meublés et les chalets
aussi avec ses 50 km de piste de ski
alpin la Bresse fait le plein de
vacanciers en quête de glisse ou de
farnienté et pour les enfants plusieurs
spectacles de Noël proposent des univers
féériques et enchantés c'est le cas de
la sorcière éphémère comédie musicale
pleine d'effets spéciaux du 26 au 30
décembre au Théâtre du Trianon Valérie
gager et Mathieu drejou je m'appelle
éphémère j'ai 13 ans dans 2 jours et je
suis une sorcière ratée
le bras la jamb la jambe et j'aimerais
un peu plus
d'énergie avec germion une gen belle
mère qui sob à faire d'elle une sorcière
accompe mais sur éémère la magie n'it
[Musique]
pasette coméie écrite
pour de Noël
pouruse on avait épuisé la bibliothèque
de lecture enfantine de la maison et
puis elle voulait de nouvelles histoires
alors j'ai commencé à lui raconter comme
ça en improvisant une histoire de
sorcière puis le lendemain voulait la
suite et le sur lendemain la suite la
suite encore et puis donc j'ai écris
toute l'histoire ça ça m'intéresse le
spectacle mélange les tours de magie les
chansons et d'effrayants effets de
lumière
[Musique]
noire il y a des moments où ça vous a
fait un peu peur oui où il y avait où il
y avait la grosse bête quand il s'est
approché on croyait qu'il allait tomber
nous manger ça m'a fait sursauter quand
quand il y avait le feu qui sortait du
[Musique]
Chaudron auprès d'Ariana l'araignée et
du chîn Sylvestre éphéè va apprendre à
surmonter ses
peurs c'est un enfant qui est confronté
avec un monde qui est parfois un peu un
peu dur il y a des passages un peu
douloureux mais elle passe ces cap là et
puis elle grandit elle elle se
transforme elle se
trouve demain nous ouvrons une grande
entreprise de bonheur le bonheur pour
tous ce spectacle enchanteur est sur les
routes depuis 3 ans
plus
c'est éphémère la sorcière peut-être pas
tant que
[Musique]
ça la mort d'un pianiste et d'un
compositeur de jazz exceptionnel Oscar
Peterson est décédé hier soir à son
domicile de la R de Toronto il était âgé
de 82 ans Oscar Peterson l'un des
canadiens les plus connu au monde
s'était rendu célèbre par une maîtrise
exceptionnel du piano et surtout un
style transition entre le boogie et le
bibop on
[Musique]
l'écoute et avant de refermer ce journal
je vous rappelle les deux principaux
titres là en Mauritanie une famille
française a été attaquée par des
brigands sur une route à 250 km à l'est
de noakchot il y a quatre morts dont
deux enfants la 5è personne de père de
famille a été grièvement blessée par B
et puis la célébration de Noël au
Vatican bien sûr par le pape Benoît 16
qui a dévoilé la crèche mais aussi à
Bethléem où la cérémonie devrait avoir
cette année un faste particulier avec
l'arrivée massive des croyants 30000
pèlerins sont attendu ainsi se termine
ce journal dans quelques instants la
météo de Laurent romechco 20h50 un film
avec Tom h le Pôle Express très joyeux
Noël à vous tous si vous avez oublié de
mettre le chapon au four il ne vous
reste plus que le jambon fromage bon
appétit et bon réveillon n'oubliez pas
de mettre vos chaussons devant la
cheminée pour le Père Noël et je vous
retrouve demain à 20h très bonne soirée
sur France deh
[Musique]
revoir
l'info en continue c'est aussi sur
France
[Musique]
2.fr